before we begin i'd like to give thanks
to the sponsor for this video
guardian tales what is guardian tales
you might be asking guardian tales is
the hottest new mobile rpg
set to take you on a blast to the past
guardian tales has all the perks and
good stuff from the classic overhead
rpgs packaged in some cute pixel
graphics
guardian tails is running a new update
event right now a new three-star hero
noble succubus bianca joins the fray
along with a new world with many stages
and quests
and the best part of it all free summons
as a gacha game player
nothing brings more joy than free summon
events and starting september the 26th
guardian tales is gifting everyone with
10 free summons per day
for up to a total of 50 free summons so
there's no time to waste
head over and take the dive with
guardian tales all you have to do is
click the link and download the game to
join the fun
[Music]
2020 has been a wild year and that's an
understatement
in the anime industry however it will
forever be considered a year full of
ups and downs the industry is actually
so strong right now with the plethora of
sequels and great shows in one season
alone
what a way to start off the decade huh
as i often say though this creates the
inevitable situation where there are
some shows that get overshadowed by the
more hyped sequels
or the series that seemingly grabbed the
anime world by the neck and are the only
ones that the community can talk about
this week we're running down some of the
shows from 2020 that deserve
more love than what they're getting at
the time of writing this before we start
i'd like to encourage you to subscribe
and if you enjoy vinitube content let's
work together to hit that next milestone
for this channel
[Music]
it seems that once in a while you have
these school setting shows where the
focus is about a human and a ghost or
some spiritual being teaming up to deal
with supernatural threats heck winter
2020 had two of them albeit with
completely different approaches and
settings i think that on paper not a lot
of people would find toilet bound hanako
kun anything too special compared to
inspector
its primary seasonal comparison but that
is to be expected it seems to be your
relaxed action comedy
almost sort of like a wackier version of
inspector however i think that hanako
kun really takes it to another level
with the chemistry of the two main
characters the characters in hanako kun
are a joy to watch
especially the main lead i also like how
the arcs are quite quick and enjoyable
and they easily flow into one another is
toilet bound hanako con an unpopular
show
not by a long shot is it better than a
lot of people give you credit for i
definitely think so
[Music]
up next at number nine is darwin's game
[Music]
smartphone death games city-wide battle
royales logical leaps here and there
it sounds like the formula for a
forgettable seasonal edge fest to me by
all critic measures
darwin's game has all the check boxes
ticked for seasonal trash but it's
actually a lot more enjoyable than most
people give it credit for and i think
that in anime
enjoyment is king yeah i said it maybe
it's because i'm a big shonen or action
light novel fan that i have the amazing
ability to suspend belief or overlook
things in favor of flair
but darwin's game i believe is a lot
better than most of its relatives it's
great as setting up cliffhangers how the
characters are written and how they
interact is my jam and i think the
kaname's growth from start to end is
really a pleasure to watch if you're in
for some high octane action and popcorn
entertainment
pick this show up or another similar
show that i'll be talking about later on
the list while you're at it check out
the manga for darwin's game as well it's
at its last arc and things have taken a
huge twist and shift in tone
[Music]
i consider this next one a kind of
pioneer for the genre
my next life as a villainess the
reincarnated as a villainess plot's
pretty much
become a genre now but i think a lot of
you had your first exposure to it
through this anime i personally had that
experience too and i have to say i
enjoyed the whole ride with katarina
through and through i don't know what
the secret was it could be the charming
and charismatic characters it could be
the fresh take on the isakai genre
being an oto may reverse haram and all
it could even be me finding stakes in
katarina's quest to avoid bad endings
but whatever it is there's a lot to like
about this funny and entertaining series
the show got quite the following when it
did air however once the season finished
not a lot of people
really talk about it much anymore which
i think is a big shame i won't say that
the show is a masterpiece or anything
like that
but i did think that it would be the
flag bearer for the reincarnated as a
villainess genre to start taking off
into the somewhat mainstream in a way
i think it has kind of done its job rank
seven in line is
fog hill of five elements so
this one's a no-brainer inclusion on
this list i've talked about how much i
like the short series for many videos
now and the show has virtually
no traction that's understandable given
its nature but like to once again
encourage you to watch this show
be much shorter than a full anime series
foghill is easy to go through and for
the short running time you get treated
to a lot of amazing fight scenes and
unique art style that gives its own
signature flair the story is also pretty
decent too but i think that the
animation and art direction is really
where fog here shines you'll be
hard-pressed to find a lot of titles
that are as good as it in these
departments watch out
i'm telling you chinese anime is about
to take the world by storm
it's
a whisker away is our sixth entry a
whisker away is one of the 2020 anime
films that generated quite a bit of buzz
when it was first announced
then circumstances forced it out of
theaters
then it became a netflix movie and then
it ended up being a one-and-done thing
come to think of it i thought that it
would end up having a fate like this
i'm not saying that that's a bad thing
but i really think that without the
messed up situation of the world at
large a whisker away could have been a
lot better and definitely more popular
after watching it i really don't mind
that it's not on par with say
a miyazaki or a shinkai film leave the
comparisons and the expectations aside
and a whisk away ends up being a
whimsical and fantastic adventure into
the beauty of magical love
it also helps that mari okada is at the
helm and i like her work generally
speaking
it really makes me feel that it's a
disney film but in anime form with the
way it looks and how the story flows
with that being said you should give
this movie a watch if you haven't done
so yet
it's a fun adventure that would provide
a fun way for you to pass a weekend with
the family or your loved one at number
five we have kakushigoto
when i first read the synopsis of
kakushigato i immediately thought of the
infamous era manga sensei a far more
wholesome take on the secret identity
storyline and minus the incest subtext
am i the only one who thought of it in
that way however when i was done with
kakushigoto i got an experience closer
to usagi drop now it's certainly a great
way to subvert expectations right
gagusigato is primarily a comedy no
doubt but it does have a lot of
genuinely touching and heartwarming
moments that help complete the
experience the characters are easy to
sympathize with and i know
some of you can also relate to the
situation of having a double identity
i know i certainly did when kakushi got
there was airing i didn't notice that
much traction on the show so i included
it in here because i think it's severely
underrated come in for the comedy and
you'll come out with some feels and some
honestly dramatic and melancholic
moments
[Music]
rounding out our pre-top three is glyph
near at number four
[Music]
okay so this is the show that i
mentioned back in the darwin's game
entry like darwin's game gleipner deals
with the idea of a survival game with
gifted people gaining powers from a
supernatural source while i like the
overall character designs for darwin's
game more
leipner has far better production values
and a much darker tone and atmosphere
just check out the top 10
fights video that i'll be linking up
there and be amazed at how much effort's
been put in this show's animation
personally i just like how all in
gleibnig goes in its gritty survival
premise while darwin's game operates
more like a traditional ensemble shonen
gleipner decides to skirt classic
conventions and deal with more morally
grey perspectives and a revenge
storyline the atmosphere is also darker
and more of a mystery when i stick to
the belief that dark doesn't equal good
it works like a charm in glipener the
only downer for the show in my opinion
is it's kind of nonsensical last episode
because they wanted to have a climax
with the last boss fight but the manga
version of that fight is a bit far off
from where the episode count ended
taking advantage of the barren spring
season gleibener got some traction when
it was airing however i think that
barring circumstances the show would
have gotten buried in obscurity given
its stage in the community right now it
does deserve more love
really it does
after going through the synopsis and
getting the general feel of the series i
knew immediately where doro hidara would
be in the anime popularity ladder so to
speak dora hidura prides itself on its
black comedy
crass humor over the top violence and
gritty atmosphere
it doesn't exactly tell the story of an
underdog learning to survive the
dog-eat-dog world like what vinland
sagar or other similarly dark shows
would have done
for me dorihidoro didn't follow the
traditional formula for mainstream
success however i knew that with how all
in it went on those mature themes and
story execution that it would find
itself as an underrated gem by some
people
kind of like a cult classic and that's
exactly what it became in a season with
haikyuu and other shows with more
mainstream appeal like beaufort
dorahidoro is probably at the exact spot
where i expected it to land still if
you're up for some mature and wild
entertainment
dora hidura might just be the hidden gem
for you almost making it to the top but
not quite
second place on the list goes to
decadence
i really like decadence i know a lot of
people have written it off as just
another derivative of the attack on
titan formula but with the seasons close
i really think that it's ascended and
come to its own over the few months
still i can't understand why it doesn't
seem as popular
as something as good as it would warrant
the crisp and fluid visuals aside
i do admit the decadence does take a
while to kick things into a high gear
you've got the amazing fight in the
opener that i talked about in a previous
video but it did turn out to have a
pretty slow start
overall i like decadence because of how
original it feels you can quickly tell
that a lot of love and care has been put
into crafting it it's world building is
good the characters are fun to watch and
there are many themes that you wouldn't
expect from this series at first glance
stop sleeping on decadence guys
at the top this time is it invaded
when it invaded came out i was sure that
it was going to be the hit of the season
who doesn't love a cop show with a lot
of psychological thriller elements
not exactly too many people it seems now
this isn't a knock on the show and it's
fan base but for something that looked
like
psychopaths i expected a bit more pull
and fanfare coming in i guess it's the
comparisons though to the masterpiece
that is psychopaths which makes it
invaded unappreciated setting aside the
comparisons i believe that it has a lot
going on for itself in its own right
at its core it's a pretty nice sci-fi
mystery that could have pretended to be
a serious live-action crime drama it
also has a lot of well-written
characters that avoid or subvert the
usual tropes that you see in the medium
so yeah
stop calling it a poor man's derivative
of psychopaths and give id invaded
a shot it's definitely gonna be worth
your time 2020 has got a lot of hot
stuff buried underneath the heavy
hitters right it's really worth the
journey to go through all of these one
at a time while you're waiting for the
big sequel that you're anticipating in
the coming few months would you like
more content like this in the future
make sure to tell me in the comments
section down below
you might also want to give your own
version of the list so that we can get
to know you a little bit better
before leaving make sure to leave a like
and subscribe to the channel and don't
forget to ring the bell so you can be
the first in line for the next video
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game guardian tales the links in the
[Music]
description
you